hi there steve kaufman um i'm going to
do two videos today
uh in answer to two of the most common
questions or comments that i get
both here on my youtube channel and at
my blog the linguist on language blog or
even that link
the first question which i can deal with
pretty quickly is
does it make sense to study more than
one language at the same time
the second question is
uh how much of an advantage was it that
i was born in sweden spoke swedish till
i was five
and then moved to canada
how much of an advantage was that to my
language learning so i'll deal with the
second question in a separate video and
i'll address the question of studying
two languages at the same time
my answer to this is usually
that i have a lot of trouble studying
two languages at the same time
i find that you need a lot of
intensity
to be successful at language learning
you have to there's a sort of a
transformation that takes place you have
to create some habits some language
habits in the brain
and so for that reason alone i like to
concentrate on one language
um
i find that i get hooked on the language
that i'm studying
i've said in one of my one of my pieces
that learning a language is like falling
in love it's difficult to fall in love
with two people at the same time for
most people so i tend to get hooked on
the one language
as an example right now i'm still with
my russian and i'm trying to
steal time away from it for korean i'm
finding it difficult to do
uh it takes some special motivation like
prior to my trip to
portugal i was able to take time away
from russian and i spent two or three
months on
portuguese um
the uh you know recently i was gonna do
some videos in in spanish so i i got a
hold of some spanish
uh audio books on link and read them and
listen to them
uh so i i often say you know at the very
least i want to spend 80 percent of my
time on my major language and perhaps 20
on the minor and typically the minor
language has to be one that i'm already
fairly well along in
i can't start um a language from scratch
and hope to get anywhere if i'm only
spending 20 percent of my time on it
that's me other people may
you know like doing things differently
one other thing i should say about
studying more than one language is
if i wherever i do take time away from a
language which i've done in the past
like um
you know when i was on i can't remember
what the cantonese i took time away to
really focus on swedish i did a lot of
listening to swedish audiobooks and
reading because i was going to sweden
when i come back from that period of
intensive exposure to swedish
all of my languages improved
time that i i take a break from language
a and focus on language b for a month
three months six months
a year
uh all the languages improve so i i very
definitely believe
that a that any language that you work
at intensively
uh particularly with a a big focus on on
on input-based learning and also of
using it
uh rather than sort of trying to learn
rules and isolated word lists so if
you're really in the language
uh
whatever progress you achieve you're
going to keep that's been my experience
a period of what i called in one post
at my blog benign neglect is not going
to damage you you'll lose a bit of
traction you'll forget a few words but
when you get really back into it you'll
do better than before so in summary i
find it difficult to study two languages
at the same time
i tend to focus at least eighty percent
on one
the other twenty percent i can only
really use to refresh languages
that where i already you know i am
fairly well along
i could not undertake a new language or
one where i'm at a very low level like
my korean uh just by spending 20 of my
time on it i have i need more
uh but so my recommendation is to go in
in spurts
uh six months on one
then you can go six months on another
uh it's been my experience and if you do
that you won't lose ground really in the
first one in fact you'll probably
improve in it so there you have it
that's my answer on whether it makes
sense to study more than one language at
the same time thank you for listening